What book are you reading right now?
So, the book that I'm reading right now
is called "The Giver",
and that is actually, interestingly,
it's a book written for young adults,
and I found that I'm finding it a very profound book
that's discussing, you know, the future
and what different options are.
And what inspires me the most about this book
is that you can write your own ending to it
because the ending is so ambiguous,
and my son and I have been talking
about lots of different endings to that story,
which I think is a very creative process
of dreaming about the future.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.